au centre de recherche du chum
les chercheurs se fit le rouge et réjean
lapointe et ont des champs d'expertisé
bien différent lui est spécialiste dans
la lutte contre le cancer l experte en
biomatériaux
ils ont mis leurs connaissances en
commun pour élaborer une façon
ingénieuse de s'attaquer aux cellules
cancéreuses
c'est extrêmement extrêmement
prometteurs comme approche région
lapointe dirige le laboratoire d'immuno
en oncologie ce qui consiste à lutter
contre le cancer
en utilisant les armes provenant du
système immunitaire du patient
comment on obtient ces cellules
immunitaires anticancer en fait ce sont
des cellules immunitaires anticancer qui
viennent du même patient
ces cellules sont multipliés en
laboratoire on en fait une sorte d'armé
pour lutter contre la maladie
on retourne ensuite les cellules
immunitaires dans le sang on lance
l'armée à l'assaut des tumeurs en
immunothérapie lorsqu'on utilise des
composés qui vont agir sur le système
immunitaire et le stemi tard pour agir
contre les cancers
donc c'est composent l'un une aux
thérapeutiques sont aussi taxés que les
autres traitements plus traditionnelle
malgré d'immenses progrès depuis cinq
ans cette méthode encore des limites
comme un voyage dans le sang les
cellules anti cancer c'est par pays dans
l'ensemble du corps du patient
les troupes sont dispersés l'assaut est
imprécis le défi qu'on a c'est que
souvent les composés qu'on va donner aux
patients vont aller partout dans le
cadre de la difficulté à atteindre la
tumeur pour être efficace l'armée doit
donc être composée de dizaines de
milliards de cellules pour espérer
atteindre les demies la tumeur
et ça peut prendre quatre cinq six
semaines avant qu'on ait le nombre
suffisant de cellules et en plus on les
fait tellement proliférer vigoureusement
qu'il vienne un peu fatigué le bio j'ai
développé par ce fil rouge professeur au
département de génie mécanique à l'école
de technologie supérieure pourrait
rendre ce type de traitement beaucoup
plus efficace au départ on voulait
développer un gel qui soit injectables
qui puisse servir de réservoir à des
cellules pour n'importe quel type de
thérapie cellulaire en présentant ses
recherches sur les bio gel elle a attiré
l'attention du professeur lapointe
lorsque j'ai vu la présentation de
sophie j'ai immédiatement compris que on
pouvait utiliser son biogen car je vais
le coût et la semis au gel est très
particulier d'abord il est constitué à
la base de poudre de carapace de
crevettes de matane
mélangez un ingrédient gélifiant on a
donc fait simplement mélanger ces deux
agents et lorsqu'ils seront mélangés ils
vont rester liquide à solution à la
température pièce mais ensuite ils vont
ce génie fier à 37 degrés et donc c'est
tout le la beauté de la chose le biogen
devient un moyen de transport idéal pour
l'armée de cellules immunitaires comme
le gel est liquide à température pièce
on peut facilement l'injecter dans le
corps à proximité de la tumeur soit
l'aide d'une aiguille ou d'un cathéter
mais une fois à l'intérieur du corps le
gel se solidifie ce qui fait que les
cellules anti cancer reste concentrée
autour des cellules cancéreuses
l'attak est beaucoup plus ciblées
pour lui d'en donner des centaines de
milliards dans le sens on peut peut-être
en mettre juste quelques millions dans
un gel dans un bio gère qu'on va
recoller sur la tumeur et elles vont
sortir du gel pour aller tuer la turquie
est immédiatement à côté leur découverte
c'est l'espoir mais les chercheurs
préviennent ils leur reste encore
beaucoup de travail et de recherches
avant de pouvoir administrer ce type de
traitement sur les humains ici vincent
maisonneuve radio-canada m'ont rien